les Chéries allez on va revenir surt ce
qui s'est passé à la té tiens sor un
sujet qui va lui faire plaisir à Sora ma
responsable beauté fiente
elle m'a cassé la tête depuis tout à
l'heure est-ce que tu vas parler du
froid est-ce que tu vas parler du froid
est-ce que tu vas parler du froid oui je
vais parler du froid parce que le froid
est au cœur de toutes les discussions
dès que vous avez quelqu'un le matin au
téléphone c'est insupportable ouais tu
as vu comme il fait froid B oui bah
alors couvre-toi me fais pas
chier non mais franchement c'est
insupportable est-ce que moi je vous ai
déjà appelé en disant il fait froid non
non ah non vous avez j'ai jamais appelé
tout
[Rires]
court tu seras pas [__] en chef mais
tu t'es quand même
distingué alors quand il neige en France
c'est vrai qu'on est pas prêt PAS prê du
tout pour neig fr je vous le dis he
alors dès qu'on est dès qu'il neige moi
j'ai juste une question à vous poser
est-ce que les rats ont peur de la neige
ah ouais bonne question est-ce qu' un r
on a déjà vu un rat courir dans la neige
sur tranquille en après ski euh
non le rat est-ce que le est-ce que le
froid et la neige font que les les rat
vont se planquer truc avis Mo
ai ils aiment les chain ah ils vontir
dans mon c'est
con qu'est-ce que tu fais toi ça va avec
ton regarde ils hibern pas il on il de
laige donc ils sortent ils ont peur de
rien les sans décon truc de fou c'est la
saison des faux plafond ils vont dans
les faux plafonds pour échapper au froid
je vous jure sa j'avais un fond plafond
chez moi il y avait pas sais ce que j'ai
fait et ben un jour tu demand à ma mère
me regarde c'est VI en plus histoire de
ouf je je m'amusé en fait j'avais
j'avais des bottes j'étais j'étais avec
un copain qui s'appelle micoon quion
appel micoastico
euh touour en prison en
Thaïlande c'est vrai plus non non il est
sorti c'est un pote à moi il est STI est
sorti il est sorti ah
[Applaudissements]
al il a eu une permission derrière lui
tout ça il a un Foy derrière lui frérot
attends c'est mon frère on habitait
ensemble on habitait ensemble et
écoute-moi bien on s'amusait en fait on
prenait notre chaussures moi j'a des
bottes on essayait de mettre la
chaussure le plus haut possible ah ouais
je l'ai fait ça et j'avais pas vu qu'en
fait moi ma mère en fait on avait un
faux plafond et à un moment moi la
chaussure elle est monté la chaussure
s'est plantée dans le plafond j'ai fais
un trou ma mère la tête de ma mère
écoutemoi bien elle s'est réveillée
parce que ma mère elle faisait des
siestes toute l'anné jour toute l'anné
jour elle kiffit des sièes tu vois comme
ça frère elle entend un truc chelou tu
vois fait qu'est-ce que c'est j'appelle
ton père il va
t'esquinterre elle arrive comme elle
voit la p dans le bail
j'appelle tout de suite ton père et mon
père il est arrivé com travaill à côté
de la maison mon père il arrive 22
ans et mon père je me rappelle
j'habitais dans une pente et j'entendais
comme ça il mettait le frein à main
comme et je
disais et jeentendais prière porte deème
porte il arrivé et d'en bas il je vais
t'c alors c'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois c'est un mec super sympa
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer non
non mais sans rigolz c'est vrai et donc
les faux plafonds maintenant tu me dis
qu'il y a des rats donc si je me plante
ma chaussure je peux toucher un rat ou
absolument ah ou en cas de forte chaleur
ou de grand froid il se réfugie là pour
être à l'abri et ils s'y reproduisent
évidemment bien sûr oui oui ça can
beaucoup un r énormément les rats et les
souris dans les faux plafonds il y en a
plein ça se reproduit à vitesse grandv
ça se démultiplie mais tout à l'heure ce
RA dans la loge a vu une souris passer
ah hein là dans le dis pas ça c'est fini
il va délocaliser sour petit non non non
non une souris c'est petit même les
petits zizi peut faire du
mal non mais on préfère les souris au
rat bah bien sûr ou un r de façon je
vous dire moi un rat je l'ai déjà croisé
de trois fois qui ont voulu me mettre
des coups de pression ça s'est terminé
comment frère tranquille je le
prends par les
yeux tu sais qui je suis a on ensemble
tu vois il me dit c'est toi qui a fait 5
million 5 sur un bêtisier sur
France
non non j vousz vu une sourise fer de
télé alors oui c'est
vrai tout à l'heure nous a
dit les gars on était dans le fr on est
arrivé sur les ça rien à voir ça va toi
mamie oua super t'as pas entendu tu as
perdu ça va non j'attends ouais très
bien tu sais tu croyais jamais arrivé
jusqu'àuc
2024 oh
2024 inespéré jamais tu aurais cru
arriver jusqu'à cette date mon frère
c'est un truc de
ouf mais je te jure que c'est vrai c'est
un truc de ouf toi toi on dirait que tu
viens tout droit des années genre la
guerre tu vois genre toi normalement
elle vient direct des tranchées les
tranché 2024 ét téléporté sans déconner
ça va par contre tu as pas changé
toujours de non ah ben ça c'est enfin
c'est pas nouveau mais je bien que c'est
pas mais je l'ai retrouvé je l'ai jamais
V tu l'as pas acheté hier
le mettait
jamaisou tu l'rouvé
repère-le allez regardez on est pas prêt
pour le Frid regardez c'éit
lesgit bloqué depuis plusieurs heures
sur l'autoroute enneigée un gros bordel
j'ai jamais vu ça ces automobilistes se
retrouvent piégés ce matin en route pour
travailler au marché de ringis ce
francilien s'agace là ils ont pas
anticipé quoi la neige est tombée ça a
fondu ça ça a gelé et puis bah voilà en
île-defance la neige a recouvert la
chaussée vers 1h du matin environ 150 km
de bouchon ont été recensés dans la
région dans les ivelines les
déneéigeuses sont à pied d'œuvre depuis
4h30 ce matin mais la chaussée reste
glissante prudence donc si vous prenez
la
route
Frid le
froid mais il y a un double scandale
pour moiier non mais je vais vous
expliquer raison je vais vous expliquer
le premier scandale c'est que les
pouvoirs publics ne font rien contre le
froid comme ça arrive tous les 6 ans ils
se disent on s'en fout on a 60 pèeteuses
pour déniger deux autoroutes toutes les
voies d'île-de-fance et d'autres régions
ça c'est un scandale on ninvestit pas et
l'autre scandale c'est que les
autoroutes quand même c'est payant il y
a des péages bien les compagnies
autoroutières vous laissent galérer
pendant des heures sur la route et ne
font rien non mais Cyril c'est
impossible sais aux États-Unis tu as des
tu as un système d'alerte systématique
quand il fait très froid quand il y a de
la neige tu reçois des sms on t'interdit
de prendre la route on te déconseille
bah ouais mais c'est un pays qui c'est
un pay c'est un pays qui a beaucoup plus
de qui a beaucoup plus d'intempérie et
de et lorsqu'il y a de la neige c'est
beaucoup plus problématique comm on et
systématiquement tu reçois des des des
systèmes d'alerte qui font que tu
t'aventures pas mais nous on a un demi
cm et tu as 350 km de
bouchon j'ai vu la neig la nouvelle
Orland là sur le parc de SW je peux te
dire que j'ai sur le parc
de l'Angleterre je peux dire que j'ai
jonglé mais je peux dire qu'il y avait
des flocons je peux te dire tu vois des
des boules de bire ou à la nouvelle
orléand ouais ou à orléand
plutôt comme on dit là-bas comme
j'habitais là-bas moi j'hitais à la
nouvelle orléand j'étais on appelle ça
New
Orleans rappelle j'étais chantter dans
un gospel ah oui s'appelait
comment la corale gospel s'pp comment
sur B
le le le Babaou le Babaou le Babaou vous
vous souvenez de la chanson non bien sû
allez-y
Babou
taeule non non chantit que des trucs
genre tu sais genre à notre façon genre
des trucs tu vois mais connu il y avait
John Smith ta
gueule il est plus s en chef du coup
quoi il est plus s en chef du coup ouais
ça y est
tu pour l'instant il n'y a plus deur à
la
table la table oui je vis vous dire
merci d'exister non mais ça
c'est sans déconner non avec tes
lunettes on dirait un
informaticien vont bien déjà il a tout
fait pour se faire remarquer avec son
son vêement évite les
vannes je ten supplie je te demande un
truc évite reste dans
l'info je vais vous dire en fait ceux
qui doivent rester dans l'Info Jacques
cardose c'est
tout
rest focus là non mais c'est bon